we get learning attends every time we
talk yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel it's
like it's like it's like like instill in
our lives and no those look I had great
Indians interviews with him like no no
no no I have the best footage like yes
yes I burped Burdett like I have people
kind of like now if you wanna have good
footage of my favorite either the four
people that you need to contact right
now no they have the best [ __ ] like they
have the best [ __ ] like it's like Joy
Diaz has some good stuff joy do you like
oh no no brother when you when you
[ __ ] when you die now we'll put
this [ __ ] out like oh this is gonna be
spectacular
Joe Church
I love joy Diaz man are you saying we're
in that level where we captured some
unique Olly
yeah man is it's every interview is is
different with different people that's
the craziest thing it's like just like
my stand-up I'm different with different
play with this is genuinely me it's just
a different people bring out their like
I'm very comfortable with Burt Greenberg
talk about what if I laugh a lot we
didn't cuz he's just what's Mike coming
to your room with no shirt on and no
shoes they told L went on they'll pay
and he's like so we worry about single
mother all right cuz your room is
amazing right now not right
like instead of it's a weird thing and
then R is a little weird and I always
like you know we should do shows
together then do a podcast mm-hmm and
then you think about it like and then
you go to Joy's and get wasted with Joey
and you waiting to do rogen you want to
do Tom's go you want you know you just
people that you want to do mm-hmm
you know you wanna say I wanna I have a
goal of doing these podcasts I wanna do
you know times go on I'm gonna do
rogon I wanna do I wanna go on I wanna
be the first person to ever go on um
build birds Park and I think he just
does his by itself he does like yeah
okay just just medium mm-hmm the only
person they ever do they go down in
history and I put that in the credit the
only man to ever do build birth and I
was gonna be my alright I think I'll
risk my sit out Comedy Central is
they're like yeah cuz it's a give it up
for a Lisa T the only man to do
bilborough's but that's my goal with
this podcast cuz so many communes have a
podcast that I want to talk to comedians
in a way they've never been talked to
before and like get more on the insights
of their process and like how they got
to where they are and things like that
because so many comics have a podcast
I'd like this to be one where people can
come to learn I don't I don't do
everybody's [ __ ] it doesn't just know
that I don't
I by no means do I do everybody's
[ __ ] respect
I have no desire I do Joe Budden's
mmm-hmm but I don't have a desire to do
it I do anything with Nikki Glaser
anything with Nikki Glaser well thanks
for letting us be a part of that
exclusive list Ali Siddiq oh yeah so
it's only a phase a very exclusive list
worldwide 20 people I did a podcast
worldwide it's not a lot of people
because I don't like talked a lot of
people you you I've been in radio
interviews what
you think I like man you know I would
shout you in and if you liked it so he
didn't guys like that like like a lot of
who the [ __ ] is you talking to on the
radio interview so I don't like doing a
lot didn't people live you yeah
and I'm [ __ ] with you [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] stooge and if you like your what
we gonna do this over game is he told me
is he gonna beat my anything in like I
don't give a [ __ ] about coming up in
time when you can ban me and do [ __ ]
mmm-hmm with me when you can't do like
me that they've been the prism that no
he not ever going back like I'm a whole
court in the street they ever try that
[ __ ] it's not a lot you can [ __ ]
say it do to me that I'm like yo man
either you don't have to try to prove
that [ __ ] that I'm exactly when I say I
guarantee I'm a [ __ ] prove it mm-hm
I don't come from a place where you can
say some shitty you can't do it I can I
was six years in prison I am phone of
here 19:25 if I say I would do something
if I make that decision
send me no I'll [ __ ] kick your teeth
down your throat just know you're gonna
have to go to the dentist and you're
capable that's what scares just no man
you [ __ ] going to the dentist is like
I'm telling you you didn't you didn't
push me - but my yo man I hope you eat
sugar babies and you used to start
[ __ ] me there I need a bad guy but
nobody else I tried my best not to get
it's nothing cuz it's always my fault no
matter I knew could shoot me and then I
beat it there then they goes I see see
that's why I'm a [ __ ] shot you cuz
you wit like no no I got shot it up you
know something [ __ ] you my god look
everybody's [ __ ] me what else I want
to end this before I get kicked in the
teeth
not me you claim a nice ass up our our
our dialogue which is very my homily
Howard Cosell dish I'm gonna go watch
some of that reference why would you see
the Reverend you go [ __ ] fallout
you like it yeah that is it's kind of
like they were was at each other all the
time that is a bit I always had the best
got their interviews and it's awesome i
deadline was my homily their critics
tainted you not what you used to be and
how and heathrow how go say he said well
Howard I talked to your wife last night
she said you have the manage every time
I'm gonna go watch something I'm gonna
come to your show tonight - I'll see the
master at work always learn seeing your
work man